for many it would be a dream come true
to work on cruise liners like this
Martin Cornelius is living that dream
he's been working as an apprentice at
the Maya valve shipyard since last
September from I get up at 5:00 a.m. and
right to work my bike I start at 6:30 we
meet in the workshop the foreman assigns
us to an area and off we go the 17 year
old could hardly wait to start his
apprenticeship the first two things he
learned wearing a helmet and protective
goggles is mandatory at all times and
secondly the shipyard is very big he
clocks up quite a few miles in a day
yeah I will walk through hall numbers
five and six almost to the end so I can
show you where I'm working in the block
assembly and what I do there when I wake
him talk
physical fitness is vital the holes are
hundreds of meters long workers at the
shipyard typically spend one year
building a cruise liner in these halls
Martin goes straight his Foreman he
hears that today's task is to install a
porthole in one of the blocks the two
then immediately get to work the
apprenticeship runs for three and a half
years Martin is in his second year of
training
he spent his first year at a vocational
College learning all the basics we learn
how the tools work in theory and then in
practice we learn about finally how to
work with a lathe you sawing milling and
other metalwork the kind of huge
passenger line is that the Maya shipyard
builds have to be constructed in stages
the work is divided into individual ship
blocks which are put together later the
construction mechanics play a key role
in all of this
and that's the job Martin is learning he
later be responsible for the interior
construction a multi-faceted job that
not everyone is suited to Martin's
training supervisor went through the
same apprenticeship himself 28 years ago
you need a basic School Leaving
Certificate with good grades especially
in math you need to be a team player and
your work ethic and social skills are
important so is your overall personality
martin caninus is one of 270 trainees
during the lunch break they all want to
know what work he was doing what the TV
crew was looking over his shoulder he
says he's spending the afternoon on
board the ship something not everyone
gets to do the workers have to line up
to be registered before they can board
the meijer shipyard specializes in
luxury cruise liners this one is nearly
ready the trainees earn nearly a
thousand euros a month so they couldn't
afford a Caribbean holiday on one of
these ships instead they have to focus
on working hard the shipyard is building
larger cruise liners these days and in
shorter time that means apprentices have
to cope with stress and working under
constant time pressure as the work
speeds up they need to keep pace it used
to take two years to build a ship of
this size no it's done in half that time
there's no shortage of work I'll
continue my training until my fourth
year just under two more years and then
hopefully get a job here the chances of
being taken on are pretty good the order
books are full soon the team will be
starting work on the next seagoing Giant